Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 93rd episode, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Are we sure those numbers are correct, Moco-chan?
No.
93?
Oh, actually they're not correct.
They aren't correct.
There's been some specials in between, right?
They have!
So maybe we're at episode 100 today, we just don't know.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for waking up bright and early to join us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Recently I feel like we've been joined by a bunch of new Ruffians!
So, to explain for you, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
To a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
Like that.
Just like that.
Moco-chan, your voice doesn't sound so rough right now.
You sure?
I think so.
Maybe a bit.
BAU BAU!
It's like a... I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
I don't get a little bit scared when you say your introduction now.
So froggy.
Yeah, no more Mococo, please.
Sound better.
You should see how it sounds when I wake up.
Moco-chan, please.
Fuwawa.
Fuwawa, can you turn around?
It's another FUWAMOCO Morning!
And the week is coming to a close already!
You know, it's the weekend soon.
But there was another peron sighting.
There's been a lot of this recently, Ruffians.
How do you feel when you see Pero, huh?
That's a good question.
Right?
Beloved.
Beloved?
That's how you feel?
Believing?
Your heart feels full?
Happy?
Ruffians!
Magical!
Concern.
Yes, that is the right feeling.
Fear.
Anxiety.
Not nice dog.
Yeah.
Well, let's see what pair was spotted this time.
Let's see.
De-den!
When you were on a walk?
What?
Did you happen to run into Pero unexpectedly?
Or while you were trying to improve your Japanese skills?
Enshashingo.
That's right!
You were walking around!
Wanted poster!
I wish.
But at least you got to remember a new Japanese word!
Ya!
No!
Yarashii!
Nasty!
And look!
You know, he put himself right in front of the garbage too!
That's kind!
You know, now it's easier to put him into the place that he belongs!
That's right!
But if you want to remember another Japanese word because of Peron,
Ah, you could learn Marui!
Round!
Yeah, that was in Shashinko, right?
Oh, it was?
Pero's very round, huh?
Maru maru maru no shike!
Yeah, marui.
Pony, pony.
But into the trash he goes.
Trash!
We hope you're still able to learn lots and lots of stuff.
Still take a lot of photos.
Hopefully you didn't ruin it.
BAU BAU!
Don't be mean to Pero.
Ruffians!
I don't know, it seems like you feel a little... You don't feel the right feelings when you see Pero, so we're gonna protect you, okay?
We're gonna protect you.
Yeah.
Got it.
Okay.
Okay, Fuwawa.
Howl!
BAU BAU.
I'm here to protect you!
Ruffians!
Let's forget about Perroccino.
Because!
Something big happened that I know you didn't forget about.
It was Shiori's birthday yesterday!
Happy birthday again, Shiori!
Yes, she had a birthday bash together with all the novelaids over on her channel.
And there was some 3D silliness going on too.
But!
Not just that.
Shiori also released her second cover song of Kyofu All Back!
Yay!
Have you listened?
Look at Shiori here.
Oh, she doesn't have a knife.
She has a single scissor.
It's one part of the scissor.
Scissors usually is just a scissor.
Ain't nobody taking a part to clean it.
Yeah, you have to be careful.
Shiori here, I think she's being careful, but... It looks a bit dangerous.
I think everything's going well.
Yeah, just she has to be careful.
It's kind of close to her head.
Maybe you should be careful.
Ah, it's okay.
But as you can see, it's super cute.
The video too, it was really something else.
You know, you have a very cute Shiori, like always, you know, trying to run off to school.
But in a 3D series game!
It was a nice mix, right?
So creative.
At FUWAMOCO, we just really love Shiori singing too!
So we're happy to be able to hear more of it.
But we're gonna be a little bit greedy.
We want to hear more!
Shiori did a really great job, so please check it out.
Also, Biboo has Kyofu on back too.
They're both very different.
One's very Biboo, one's very Shiori.
I love them both.
Also, you know it was Shiori's birthday, right?
And she released some birthday merch!
Yay!
This is Shiori looking really cute.
See?
In the kitchen there.
She'll have her whole tongs and scissors at the same time.
She's cutting up noodles for us.
Right.
Gotta hold the noodles down, make sure they don't slip away while she snip-snaps them.
Don't wiggle away.
Right.
I have times where I do that too.
Yeah?
I don't know about that.
But, well, hopefully Ruffians, you like spending time in the kitchen too.
Because Shiori's merch is so cool!
She has a beautiful acrylic panel of this Shiori here.
Look at how cute!
Kitchen Shiori!
Kitchen Shiori with the apron too!
That's a big window.
Big window behind her.
Yeah, the window in the back.
But she also has some cutlery.
It has a fork and a spoon.
And you won't be able to find these anywhere else because the handles are in the shape of a feather ink brush.
And then they also have Shiori's name engraved on them.
They're so, so, so cute!
I know they look very suitable for eating big pieces of meat!
Except maybe you'll need another knife.
Because you'll probably not want to use the spoon.
Yeah.
I don't really eat meat with a fork and spoon, no.
But you can use the fork!
She also has a very uzi shiori themed shirt and a cute mug with a decoration design that changes when you add hot water to it too.
Moco-chan!
We only have two mugs and they're small and they don't have any designs on them.
We don't need that many mugs, okay?
If we get
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Ah, Shiori said you should not microwave it.
That's kind of her.
Good advice, huh?
Yeah.
But Shiori's wedges are really really cute.
I'm very Shiori.
So we hope that you'll check them out and maybe decide to grow your kitchen cabinet too.
Kitchen cabinet?
Yeah!
Grow it by putting more bugs into it.
Cutlery.
I know.
Okay!
BAU BAU BAU!
Tasty plastic.
There's no plastic, there's only acrylic.
BAU BAU!
Unless Ruffians, you're not using plastic cutlery, are you?
It's time to get some shiori forks and spoons in hand!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
Actually, on the topic of cover songs, FUWAMOCO!
We've reached some new milestones of our own!
I think Ruffians
What a song, because we saw a bunch of your congratulations messages.
Thank you!
First, our cover of Speed's song White Love has reached 700,000 views!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
You know, while it's not at all the famous song in Japan,
It's not so well-known overseas, so... It makes us really happy that you've been listening to our voice!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And!
Also!
Our cover of Kanaya's Identity!
It hit 800,000 views!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It really makes us so, so happy to know that you like our singing and our music so much and that you've still been listening to them many, many times over, even months after they've been released.
We hope we can share some new music with you soon, okay?
So make sure that you're super enthusiastic about it when that day comes, okay?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, make sure you go listen!
Our most recent cover is Let Me Be With You, too, so maybe for a bit more of a spring vibe, yeah.
You can go listen.
Morning, too.
Right after FUWAMOCO Morning.
Perfect song, too.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Gosh, Moco-chan, what's the matter?
Did you notice, Ruffians?
That you're getting a little bit more ruff sounding, Moco-chan?
No, no.
Did you notice?
Did you see a dinosaur?
I kinda heard a dinosaur, but I don't think that's what Moco-chan's getting at.
No.
Wow.
Oh, I see a lot of good things, but that's not it.
No.
FUWAMOCO made a few changes over the last few days, right?
Yo!
FUWAMOCO!
We started doing streams with two computers!
Two perspectives on separate PCs!
Yo!
What did you think?
Dual streams!
Yo!
Well, we had our Orodoroke and Weevil Company collab on my desktop computer!
And that was together in the same room at the same time, but earlier we tried it
With me over in a separate room.
Why did you think muffins of Moco-chan are scary?
What did you think?
I was so nervous.
I wanted to call Moco-chan for help.
I can't stop laughing!
This can't be the right...
It's been pretty fun!
It's good!
Fuwawa gaming is great!
Yeah, well, it's been something that we've been trying to kind of test out here and there.
You know, we're hoping that this way you can watch both of our streams and see what both of us are up to in the game.
I think we got some interesting results already!
Yeah!
Right!
You know, and- No!
No!
Right!
What was that?
No!
Huh?
Why did you poke me?
What are you doing?
Say it again.
What?
No.
No!
Don't!
She poked me in the neck.
Why do I keep touching Mococo?
BAU BAU!
What were we talking about?
I was having too much fun with Mococo.
Interesting result!
That's right!
Well, you know, we think that depending on the type of game that we'll probably change things up a little bit.
Maybe sometimes I'm behind.
Beside, not behind.
Beside Moco-chan!
Or away, but I hope that you enjoyed it.
You know, it's a bit different, you know, being able to see us run around and do things and act on our own, right?
It's cool!
I get to hug Moco-chan in content morning!
But we'll be streaming both our perspectives at the same time again on Saturday for our first start to our Minecraft journey as well.
So maybe if you're a little curious about how does this all work, you can come and join us.
It'll be fun!
We need you to hold our paws too, okay?
Because we have no clue what we're doing in Minecraft.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
New world!
All from the very beginning.
We really need to help Ruffians.
But it'll be fun!
BAU BAU!
And also good luck to the Ruffians.
Try not to go too cross-eyed, okay?
We'll try to make things easier when we can, but sometimes it might be a little bit tricky.
It's a learning process, too.
But we'll make sure that it can be a good experience for you as well, too.
BAU BAU!
Well, for Ruffians who are following us over on Twitter, you might have seen, but I asked you for some suggestions on things to get Moco-chan healthy and maybe to make her dough feel a little bit better too.
Of course, Ruffians, you gave me a bunch of great answers, so I want to say thank you!
And I got a bunch of them, but one in particular
So, uh, by the end, I want to go get groceries just for Moco-chan here.
And...
I was gonna get umeboshi pickle pops especially just for Moco-chan.
Yeah.
Umeboshi!
Yeah!
Ume!
And you know, the store they have a bunch of different umeboshi.
They all look delicious.
Some are cheaper, some are more expensive.
So I had a hard time deciding on which one to get.
But I finally made up my mind.
And then when I turned around,
I just happened to find some really, really delicious looking umeboshi on another shelf behind me.
It wasn't in the refrigerated area, but I should have been going.
But, but, but, they look delicious, you know?
It just looked like a lot of them in comparison to the five in the pack.
So, I decided to get that one instead and I put away the other umeboshi I was gonna get and I was gonna get the delicious looking ones.
And that's when it happened.
I got back, and I showed what I got Otsumoko-chan.
And then of course, I really like umeboshi.
We both really like umeboshi.
So I was really excited to try the delicious looking ones.
And so I kind of went ahead and opened them up to try one myself first.
Ruffians!
What I bought were Ume plums.
Plums that have been used previously to make plum wine.
And, well, it was alcoholic and apparently delicious to some, but...
No.
I was so disappointed.
It wasn't at all what I wanted.
And they smelled super alcoholic and really spicy!
And it was 5.30am!
It was really early.
Yeah.
And Ruffians, I was a little bit surprised too because a lot of you were saying that we should eat them.
Eat them.
But...
Ruffians!
What are you suggesting?
You know it.
We're demon dogs.
Yeah, we don't drink alcohol.
You know it.
Plus, it's really spicy and it smells bad and it's not good for you.
Yeah, we'd much rather have something else, you know, like pond or rain.
Yeah.
Yeah, so some Ruffians do remember that demon dogs know no alcohol.
So you suggested that maybe we give them to a senpai.
So, actually, that's what we did.
We're the kind of silly demon guide dog sisters that then
After, you know, we finish playing Touhou with Marine-senchou-senpai, we open up our bag and we... Here's a tub of umeshu!
Ume plums, Marine-senchou-senpai!
This is why we have them, and... Yeah.
If you want them.
Yeah.
Hopefully she didn't think we were too silly.
Hopefully!
She said that she was going to enjoy them on rice.
Yes!
But... How are you supposed to eat them?
I don't know.
How are you supposed to eat them?
I think they're supposed to be a snack.
Maybe she thought they were umeboshi too.
I'm not sure, but hopefully she likes them either way.
BAU BAU!
I think you have them just raw.
I think it's supposed to be like a snack.
I don't know.
I don't know if you're supposed to have them on rice.
We weren't supposed to buy them.
We weren't, no!
Hopefully she likes them though.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, we're gonna be that cool high high.
BAU BAU.
BAU!
Actually, Ruffians!
We got a scoop from a Ruffian!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much to Tom8O for the impeccable journalism!
Wow, Ruffians.
It sounds like there's a brand new Earth Defense Force game coming out.
But not just that, that alone is very exciting.
But our wonderful senpai, Kiara-senpai, Gura-senpai, Ayame-senpai, they're all gonna be a part of it!
BAU BAU!
So excited!
Yeah, it looks like there's gonna be decoy balloons or something to distract or attract the aliens.
Maybe they'll have voice lines or something too.
I think so, you know, you could hear IRyS-senpai singing the song and stuff.
EDF!
It was so cool!
We're so happy for them!
We're a little envious too, huh?
We want to be in the game too!
Well, you know, we'll just have to make sure that all together with Advent we play the new EDF together.
Maybe we can get our paws on our senpai and put them to test in battle!
We'll make sure to be nice to them.
BAU BAU!
So cool!
EDF!
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at who our Doggie of the Day is today!
Our Doggie of the Day today is... Today's client!
So round!
Morning!
You look like a puppy pillow.
A puppy pillow, right?
Yeah, uh, Ruffians, you might be able to kind of tell, but Five loves to burn his face into his donut down.
Ah, it's so cute!
Right?
But, uh, as for FUWAMOCO, burning our faces into donuts.
You know what, baby?
Be careful, because you don't want to get too fluffy upon the ring.
Yeah.
Maybe not like that.
But that's okay!
There's lots of climbs to climb!
Puppy Paralyzed!
I wonder what happens if you just put your hand on climb.
Maybe it'll leave a bit of a hand print.
So fun!
But climb is apparently also very silly.
Can you tell, Moco-chan?
I can tell.
How does Clive BAU BAU?
I think he's a quick BAU BAU.
Like really quick so that Clive can eat the donuts faster.
Clive likes donuts.
We like donuts.
Clive is silly.
We are silly.
Clive is very fluffy.
FUWAMOCO.
We're fluffy, but not that fluffy.
No.
Fluffy vomit.
Great job, Clive!
Great job!
Let's go for donuts sometime, okay?
BAU BAU!
Don't get too fluffy.
A clown can't get behind fluffy.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you're still getting up and going for walks, right?
Let's take a look at where you've been walking around.
De-den!
Such a blue sky!
What a beautiful day to go for a walk!
The island is the railroad too.
It's nice that you're able to enjoy this walk here since it sounds like you can't really do it during evening.
It's peaceful.
FUWAMOCO!
Well, we hope that you'll be able to enjoy lots and lots of biking too.
Maybe that's something that you can keep special for the summer time.
You know, once it gets warmer.
Have fun!
Have fun biking!
BAU BAU!
Walk along the side of it.
Side of it.
Moco-chan, did we get a question today?
My Question of the Day is... De-den!
I think your interest in the Japanese language was largely influenced by anime and songs.
What were some of the benefits you received from learning?
You know, FUWAMOCO, well, we first really liked anime and games, and that's kinda how we got interested in Japan and learning Japanese.
But, you know, just because you like those kind of things doesn't mean that you need to go out of your way and learn the language too, because there's translations into your own language, right?
Right.
But, there was a time, you know, when we really wanted to go to Japan one day, cause you know, it'd be fun, it'd be cool.
Yeah.
And then,
Well, we kind of thought about, oh, I won't be able to communicate.
And then you'd need a translator with you everywhere you go.
That was kind of a bit frustrating to us.
So that's when we started learning.
But I think more than anything though, learning Japanese has really opened up our world.
You know, we've learned and gained so many things, met so many people, and we're just so fortunate that we can speak and understand both English and Japanese.
Right?
And yes, unfortunately,
Even though it doesn't really help out too much in our everyday nowadays now that we're outside in the Makai, but yeah.
It's good!
Yes!
So Ruffian!
Good luck!
Shashingo was really fun!
Yeah!
It was good!
And there were words like yarashii and marui and... Ninjyago.
That wasn't in the game.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions.
We're looking for your questions, your Doggie of the Day, your walks, your Pero Sightings.
Really, really, anything comes into mind.
Please tweet using the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
Okay, you understand, right?
Morning!
We're always looking, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, later this evening we have a stream coming up, right Moco-chan?
We do!
Next we have de-den.
Aoi Oni.
Yawn.
I'm a demon dog and I'm blue.
I'm not an Ao Oni.
But it does bring in the question because we have to go find our sister and escape the Ao Oni.
Are we sure that the sister isn't the Ao Oni?
We don't know.
But we're gonna do our best in a brand new remake of the classic retro horror game, indie game.
We're looking forward to it, huh Moco-chan?
We watched a little bit of the old album before, right Fu?
Am I alright?
No.
I watched videos of the old one.
A long time ago.
Yeah.
I just remember screaming on my own.
Good luck Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Let's take another peek at our schedule here.
Our schedule of Golden Week is coming to an end, but we still have a lot of fun things planned.
FUWAMOCO, we played Shashinko, but we're gonna continue our Japanese study a little bit by playing some more Kanji Dego.
Last time we made
It was a good study.
We learned some new words.
What the update is?
Not futa-megane, sou-gankyo, binoculars.
But yeah, the update!
I don't know how we're gonna do.
Maybe we made it a little bit more yasashii.
A bit easier.
Intermediate.
Right.
But we'll check it out together!
And then later we have our FUWAMOCO Minecraft journey.
Finally it's gonna be starting!
What kind of adventures are we gonna have?
FUWAMOCO Maybe you have a better idea than us.
And then we have our first collab ever with Wondame-senpai!
We're gonna be playing some clubhouse games.
Battle between Fluffy and Fuzzy and a Fluffy.
We'll see who wins.
And then on the weekend, to end off the weekend, with the Doggy Pack, we're gonna be playing Fall Guys!
Like we promised the other day, we're gonna open up the live chat two hours beforehand so that you can get some practice and beat us up even more, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians who are joining us today through the archive, here's your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU Brand New Weekend!
BAU BAU!
Please practice with us!
Have fun, Ruffians!
Have fun together!
You're gonna open up the live chat and then sleep, Moco-chan!
No.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us this week for another week of FUWAMOCO Morning.
And for waking up bright and early today to be here with us.
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Leo-ly!
BAU BAU!
We are we!
Izumi no!
BAU BAU!
Minachi!
Mai!
BAU BAU!
Bassash!
Fuki!
BAU BAU!
Soup!
Adjective.
BAU BAU!
Overlord Shinda.
Shirahoshi.
BAU BAU!
Wanchou.
Groups.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!